we've got some breaking news and I like
this news this is fun news Kamala Harris
you remember her yeah yeah that one well
she's toast she's done that means the
first two candidates who are considered
sort of major candidates in the race or
out bado my buddy bado
he's out and Kamala Harris the narc
who's interested in basically running
roughshod over every barrier in American
government in order to achieve her aims
and also to lock up everyone apparently
those are big thing Tulsi Gabbard
laughing hysterically today so Kamala
Harris has now put out an announcement
an announcement with which I share some
sympathy she put out a tweet and said to
my supporters it is with deep regret but
also with deep gratitude that I am
suspending my campaign today I share her
gratitude by the way just but I want to
be clear with you I will keep fighting
every day for what this campaign has
been about just as for the people all
the people that people you people here
is her full statement she says 11 months
ago at the launch of our campaign in
Oakland I told you all I am not perfect
but I will always speak with decency and
moral clarity and treat all people with
dignity and respect
unless I'm accusing them of the acts of
which there is no evidence and they're
going to be on the Supreme Court I say
that Center that last part was about
Brett Kavanaugh shouldn't say that but
it's sort of implicit said I will lead
with integrity I will speak the truth
she didn't lead with integrity she
didn't speak the truth she lied about
her own busting policy she lied about
her own Medicare policy like a thousand
times and no one liked her she was
really irritating and she laughed
bizarrely at all of her own jokes she
was the person at the party who suffered
from some sort of social disability and
just could not stop laughing at her own
unfunny nough says that's what I've
tried to do every day of this campaign
so here's the truth today I've taken
stock and looked at this from every
angle and over the last few days have
come to one of the hardest decisions of
my life my campaign for president simply
doesn't have the financial resources we
need to continue I'm not a billionaire
she's gonna plead poverty guys she's
poor don't you see it's that she's poor
that's that's we should feel very bad
for Kamala Harris because after all she
is she's been put upon by a man
in society by the way she had one of the
highest incomes of the 2020 presidential
hopefuls she had made about as of 2018
like over half a million dollars a year
something like that
also her husband Doug Emhoff earned
about 1.5 million dollars in 2018 so
she's not a billionaire but she ain't
exactly hurtin she says I'm not a
billionaire
I can't fund my own campaign and as the
campaign is going on it's become harder
and harder to raise the money we need to
compete in good faith I can't tell you
my supporters and volunteers that I have
a path forward if I don't believe I do
so to you my supporters it is with deep
regret but also with deep gratitude that
I am suspending my campaign today but I
want to be clear with you I am still
very much in this fight nope you aren't
really the only downside is that I live
in California now she can focus all of
her time on ruining my home state she
says I will keep fighting every day for
what this campaign has been about
justice for the people all the people
our campaign has been about fighting for
people whose voices have not been heard
or too often ignored and then jailing
them if they don't support me we will
keep up that fight let us remember we
were the first to put the injustice of
inadequate teacher pay on the national
agenda yes I am sure you're the first
person ever in American politics to talk
about how teachers should be paid more
no one has ever done it before Kamala
Harris
she said we will keep up that fight we
were the first to demand justice for our
children declaring we would take bold
executive actions to stop gun violence
well you declared a thing Kamala Harris
huge you you're the first Democrat who
has ever called for gun control ever
unbelieva groundbreaking candidate she
was to rise from her history as a person
who benefited from busing so she could
rip on Joe Biden to being Attorney
General of a state where she didn't do
her jobs being a senator rushing into
her job to being a presidential
candidate who didn't do her job so
she'll go back to being senator I mean
what what a tremendous career arc she
says we were the first to demand justice
for women with a plan to block
unconstitutional state abortion laws yes
no Democrat has ever in history
attempted to fight in favor of abortion
except for Connell Harris says we will
keep up that fight and our campaign
uniquely spoke to the experiences of
black women and people of color and
their importance to the success and
future of this party well hilariously
enough that was a fail because
she was unable to cut into the black
bass of Joe Biden a man whiter than I am
I mean well done calmly right her entire
candidacy was dependent from the very
outset on this idea that she was the
intersectional great hope that she
wasn't black and she was a woman and the
media would love her and she would pick
up female votes and black votes and that
was the base of the Democratic Party and
boom she would rock it into the White
House and as it turns out her utter
insane charmless Ness did her no favors
our campaign uniquely spoke to the
experiences of black women and people of
color sure sure did and their importance
to the success or failure of this party
our campaign demanded then no one should
be taken for granted by any political
party we will keep up that fight says
khamel Harris because no one should be
made to fight alone and I believe our
campaign showed every child in America
regardless of their color or gender that
there are no limits to who can lead and
hold positions of power in our country
except for Kamala Harris who cannot be
President cuz she's a terrible candidate
it's always funny to me when candidates
want to complete failures like what we
showed is that there are no limits to
your dreams except for my dream which
completely imploded on me like a dying
star in that way this campaign has been
so much bigger than me well so much
bigger than grammar apparently so much
bigger than I I am extremely grateful to
the hundreds of staff moved and uprooted
their lives and sacrificed time away
from their families I'm not laughing at
them today , Liz I know our fight has
been personal for each of them and of
course I could not have done this
without my husband Doug and my entire
family and friends who give up so much
to embark on this journey with me
and have supported me every step of the
way his kamo harris announcing that
she's dropping out tulsi gabbard is
sitting over here strumming the ukulele
really enjoying herself Joe Biden
putting on those sunglasses and hobbling
off into a Denny's she says I am
grateful to the thousands of volunteers
and contributors who chipped in who
knocked on doors who made calls who put
their faith and trust in me it has been
the honor of my life to be your
candidate all nine of you and I want to
be clear although I am no longer running
for president I will do everything in my
power to defeat Donald Trump and fight
for the future of our country and the
best of who we are such as when we
falsely suggest that a man engaged in a
chain gang rape of a woman without any
evidence that's the best of who we are
are says I know you will too so let's do
that together let's keep fighting for
the America we believe in in America
free of injustice in America we know can
be unburdened by what has been thank you
come on oh thank you combo ah thank you
so that is that as wonderfulness I am
I'm quite pleased that Carmel Harris is
out because she was the most fascistic
of all candidates and that includes
Elizabeth Warren people are people are
going crazy on this I mean that people
going crazy over this there's a lot of
fantastic graphics the Twitter graphic
of tulsi gabbard pushing comments up a
building is it's pretty spectacular so
that is that is some good stuff
and honestly giant giant fail giant fail
tulsi gabbard in the race longer than
Kamala Harris goodbye don't let the door
hit you on the way out Joe Biden says he
has mixed emotions on reports of Kamala
Harris dropping out of the race he
called her a first-rate intellect and a
first-rate candidate nope nope I'm old
enough to remember when Kamala Harris
decided that a major campaign issue
should be trying to force Elizabeth
Warren to say that Donald Trump should
be banned from Twitter so that is that
is pretty spectacular
goodbye catch it in the laters Kamala
Harris or never did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional leftist year don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity hit the like
button